[Music]
my name is Terry Ryan I'm a developer
advocate for Google cloud platform and
this is going to be Google cloud
platform 101 my goal here actually
before I get started in goals and I've
explained stuff I want to know a little
bit more about you who you guys are so
how many people here develop on a daily
basis all right and how many people here
do systems work on a daily basis okay
and how many people do both okay is it
because you love DevOps and is it
because your boss does hate you and
won't hire more people okay
anybody here tell developers or systems
people what to do
like any managers in the room whoa I
should have checked that before I made a
manager jokes denied all right well
luckily when you move to Google cloud
you you can kind of relieve your workers
that's good all right that kind of gives
me a good idea who you guys are and
what's going on actually I'm gonna ask
one mark into a question how many people
are currently on Google cloud platform
already okay how many people have tried
containers already great how many people
have tried some sort of serverless
solution already all right great good
mix I'm really really excited all right
so what are my goals for this talk my
goals for this talk are to tour Google
cloud platform from the perspective of
someone moving their first app over to
GCP and that usually entails this
particular set of processes and it's
it's challenging onboarding to a new
system is always difficult so I really
feel passionate about this I really like
to bring help bring people onto the
cloud easier my secondary goal which is
not as important to me is to explain all
of the various things available of JCP
it's just too much it would take too
long I'd be like an auctioneer so
instead what I'm going to do is as I go
through and we migrate this app over I'm
going to point out certain touch points
like it makes sense that we talk about
storage and we talk about other
computing things other than just virtual
machines although that's what I'll be
focused on virtual machines okay one
other thing I want to announce is that
have an internal tool called Dory which
does question and answers during our big
meetings someone sundar is answering
questions internal meetings at Google he
uses this tool we use to kind of surface
our issues it is available in the app so
if you go to the app and go to the
session you can actually do live like
basically ask questions while I'm
speaking I will go back after the talk
at the end of the talk we'll have Q&A
and if your question does not get
answered during the talk I guarantee to
you personally that I will go through
and make sure they're all answered so
please if you're interested please
participate that and we'll have live Q&A
at the end alright so how do people move
to the cloud most times when they try
out a new cloud they do pretty much the
same thing they pick up an app they have
somewhere else and they just try to move
it to the cloud and see what happens
right we call this a lift and shift you
know just moving stuff make it exactly
the same as it was just somewhere else
so I have a demo of a Minimum Viable app
I'm going to switch over to the demo
laptop and we'll drive so this is a very
bin home very minimal app it basically
is a tagging app for photos right so I
have these photos here I'm gonna go
through an ad one just to show you this
is a live system all right I'm gonna go
through and say okay upload we're gonna
add some tags I may have done this
repeatedly to the point where my browser
just gives me these options I'll head
upload it's there it's all saved all
right there it is so we have a list of
pictures we have a list of tags that
humans create to tag those pictures
pretty easy pretty straightforward
pretty simple we're gonna switch back to
the presentation all right and let's
just talk about the architecture this is
so I know none of you guys none of you
folks in this room have ever done like
you've put all your stuff on a single
server and run your production app off a
single server you know no one here does
that we all know people that have done
this right so this is what we're going
to kind of use as a stand-in for like
moving a real application it's pretty
simple it's got its got application code
it's written in PHP it's got a database
to store all the tagging information and
it's got file storage in order to serve
up the images work
to move it to this where we have a
single server that only runs the
application code and all the stateful
stuff is moved to to a cloud provided
database and images and then we'll talk
will kind of take it from there and go
and do more things with it
so let's talk about our virtual machines
because that is really where this starts
right you want to you want to run this
this code on a virtual machine just in
our network so compute engine is the
tool for running virtual machines on
Google cloud platform you can get one to
96 processors 0.62 624 gigs of ram you
know 65 terabytes of persistent storage
3 terabytes of attached SSD and 208 gigs
of ram disk instead of kind of talking
about all the features and stuff I
actually am just we're going to build a
VM right in front of you so I'm gonna
switch to the laptop again we're gonna
be doing that back and forth and so this
is Google Google cloud platforms console
I'm gonna go ahead and create a new
instance here and you'll see here I can
go let's let's give it a name so I
remember I remember to delete me I'm
gonna delete it and you see I can put it
in any region I want that we have a data
center I'm gonna choose central because
that is the one that is best for the
demo and I have a number of zones right
so the first thing I do is I kind of
start to make the shape of the machine
how many processors how much memory
isn't it but let's say I have a thing
where like well 16 is too low I'll be
performance bound and 32 would be
overkill because I would be paying for
stuff I don't need I really need 20 for
one of things you can do on our platform
which I really love is you can just dial
in to exactly the number of cores you
want right so I could say I want 24
processors that way I'm not paying you
for stuff I don't use and I get the
performance I need I'm gonna switch back
though cuz I don't you know I don't need
that many processors I can go and change
my disk image and you'll see that I have
a whole bunch of flavors of OS Ubuntu
core OS containerized container
optimized OS Red Hat only down here
windows yes you can run Windows on
Google cloud platform I'm gonna stick
with what I got because I like
the defaults let's see well so am I
gonna do oh let's see when I go to
customize something I didn't show you
before is that if I want to I can add
GPUs I can also set a minimum processor
platform so if I need the features of
certain processors I can I can get that
on my on my VMs I'm gonna switch back to
basic though and then one of the last
things I'm gonna do is I'm going to
allow HTTP traffic I'm actually gonna
open up a firewall rule this is this is
the only firewall rule we have right
available right like when you're
creating because it makes sense right
it's HTTP you always have to kind of
expose you very often have to expose
those one other thing I want to show you
here is that at the bottom this is one
another my favorite feature this at the
bottom it says equivalent rest or
command line if I click on this I
actually get the the command line
commands to create this VM exactly as
I've configured it here but I can then
take that reuse it dump it into my
scripts and build like a fleet of
machines if I want to so I can I can use
this to sort of learn the CLI which is
really kind of helpful and then one last
thing I love this we have run in cloud
shell I'm gonna show cloud shell because
one of my favorite parts of DCP I'm
actually spinning up a VM that is only
just a lot of command control center
kind of VM it has all of the all the
tools to run Google Cloud like right
there and it's got a persistent home
disk so I can do things like I don't
know g-cloud compute instance list right
and all the tools are there and so I can
see I can I could basically use all of
the tools to run Google cloud platform
right on this cloud shell which is great
because now I can maintain and monitor
my whole systems without having to get
all the stuff on my laptop for example I
was working one of the demos if you've
been the showcase we all worked on that
was really hard one of the problems I
had though was that I needed to build
something in Python and I don't have the
right version of Python on my machine
and installing the right version of
Python on machine was evidently just
more than I could do but what was great
was that cloud shell already has it all
set up and re
works and so I was just able to pop over
a cloud shell get my work done and do
stuff without having a muck with my
laptop so it's great okay so I'm gonna
go and create this VM and we like to say
they take tens of seconds to start up
when a hotel room testing this before it
takes ten seconds when people are
watching it takes longer I don't know
how it knows so like look away look away
we got all right so delete means gonna
be up in now all right so that's
somewhere in the 10-second range I'm
gonna I'm gonna call that so another
great thing about the console is I'm
gonna go SSH into my machine and I
didn't pull down any certs or at least
not me manually they didn't pull down
any certs I didn't have to hook up
anything basically it's available right
within the browser and again this is
great like I can I can SSH into these
machines even if I'm not at my home
workstation let's see so just to show
this is real apt-get update gotta spell
it right and oh yeah that's right I
always forget that you have this to do
it there we go there we go
I probably pissed off half the people in
the room with that pronunciation of
Studio right sorry a little
nerve-wracking up here alright so there
we go so we've gone through we've
created a machine let's now switch back
to the live present or
creating a machine is relatively easy
and straightforward here's g-cloud is
the tool you use to interact with most
of Google a platform g-cloud compute
instances create and then you can create
whatever you want and the next thing is
to after I create a machine I need to
run commands on I need to install
software I need to configure things so
g-cloud compute SSH the name of the
virtual machine and then whatever
command you've got and then to get stuff
from your machine to your VM to get the
code on it you're gonna want to run
g-cloud compute SCP SCP and then source
and and destination just like you would
with with SCP normally so these three
commands based with these three you know
commands I can do everything I need
right I can build a machine I can
install all the proper software I need
on it and then I can push my application
code to it now obviously they're
different
wait you can do you can do all this
differently but this just is bare-bones
like let's just the easiest way to get
it done we can do this so I don't like
to talk about price but I feel like with
VMs and our technology price is a
important differentiator so I want to
talk about a little bit I promise I
won't get too salesy so one of the
things that we do is when you start
configuring machines up in the right
right right hand right half side of the
screen you see an estimate alright and
as I add resources right I add more
processors the cost per month goes up
and it goes up and I'll go you know I
went crazy right cuz Google pays for
these right when I split them up so I
like to I like to make them big and
you'll see I've got a charge now when
you break down the charge one of the
things that we do and it's really
important to know is that we have a base
charge if you're just running a machine
kind of haphazardly but if you run your
machine for a consistent period of time
up to a month we will a month being 100%
of the time you need to run and then the
next month you get another sustained use
discount we will knock a significant
portion off the price because we
appreciate having consistent load size
appreciate being able to plan better
because you you have a set size that
you're gonna keep running in perpetuity
now this is great sustainable use this
guy was great and like for for things
you weren't running all the time it's
really good but there's another option
let's talk about we're just called
preemptable VMs and you'll notice that's
significantly less but there's a catch
right because there's got to be a catch
the catch is that a persistent I'm sorry
a preemptable VM which is what you have
to flip a little setting and it becomes
preemptable preemptable VMs will
disappear sometime in the next 24 hours
and they're guaranteed to go away in 24
hours but they go away anytime so like I
have literally started up a preemptable
VM and then one SSH into it and it's
gone and I was completely confused so
why would you want these well a lot of
times we have work that we need to do
kind of whenever it gets done batch work
big data jobs well you can push the use
of those jobs as long as you have some
sort of queue set up that is kind of can
be taller
of a machine going down you can do them
for one-fifth the cost of the normal way
of doing that that operation as long as
as soon as the queue is you know as soon
as the machine goes down the Q holds you
can always request another machine
there's nothing stopping you from
requesting another preemptable machine
and then boom you're you're going
through your queue at a pretty good rate
and doing it at one-fifth the cost or
you could just spin up five times the
number of machines that get it done and
one fifth of time I think my math is a
little bit a little bit oaky there all
right so I talked about disk images we
provide disk images but you can create
your own typically what I do is start
with one of our images modify customize
make it make it unique to what I want
and then freeze it and then I can create
new machines from that which is really
helpful but I could also make them from
scratch using VirtualBox in a process
that I have never done so good luck but
it can be done IP addresses you can get
private and public IP addresses you can
you can definitely turn off public IP
addresses you can also get static or
ephemeral one of the cool things I like
is when you get an ephemeral IP address
from us if something happens and someone
shares that ephemeral IP address and now
that's the permanent IP address of the
install and you're like you know but
this could go away any time you can make
any one of our ephemeral IP addresses
just static you just say give me that
and that's mine now which is great or
you can just have a static one now they
don't cost you anything unless you take
a static one and then Park on it because
you know we're all trying to avoid the
IP for apocalypse right so we're want to
make sure that if you have addresses
you're using them firewall kind of
briefly talked about that you create a
rule open open port 3306 on TCP and then
you that rule tag a name so that would
be my SQL for those or playing along at
home and then you tag machines with
those those rules and that's how you
open up the firewall want to take a
slight detour and talk about cloud cloud
shell a really live cloud shell it's a
great developer tool it's a really great
way of not having to have this stuff on
your machine all the time I didn't show
it but there's actually a code editor
that you can use so you can actually
edit code on the fly
in like you know kind of reasonable
syntax highlighting everything really
helpful when you're in a pinch when
people are calling you and you are not
near your computer or your own personal
computer alright we're back
there's one last consideration I want to
talk about talking about our VMs on our
network and our setup when you create
one of our VMs on our network you don't
have to do any setup to make one in one
data center talk to another by default
in one project all your machines talk to
one another and they use are really
really high powered back-end network to
do that and so instead of having to go
to like a different zone and find like
oh this data center has these machines
and then this data has they're all in
one project and so this means you can do
kind of crazy fun things especially with
our network so I'm going to switch over
to a demo and I want to take a selfie if
that's ok I'm gonna take a selfie with
all of you I hope that's ok if it's not
we'll blur out faces eventually that's
okay no one's alright so here we gar
alright we're gonna and boom yeah
alright and so let me we're use it this
was this was the test right I am clearly
not pleased with any of you know I'll
upload this and over fresh oh come on oh
I didn't upload you actually have to
upload like you have to press the button
so here we go we're uploading there we
go very uh all right you know what I'm
gonna roll with it so so we're going to
do is I'm taking this picture and you'll
see that I have this map I have I have
machines and all of these data centers
and I set them up really easy just with
the script just like I showed you and
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take this
picture and bounce it around our network
and every time it hits a different point
on the network it we're gonna stamp it
as if it had like a little passport
stamp right and you can see it happening
in live real-time we're actually
traveling so we went from Taiwan to
Tokyo to Sydney to Oregon to Iowa to
Virginia to London to Frankfurt San
Paulo faster than I could say it out
loud we did it in 4.4 seconds with six
600 milliseconds or so of processing
what's great about this is I didn't have
to do anything with the network to get
this to work it just worked out of the
box and that's something that I really
like having tried other providers like I
get spoiled with this like not having to
do a tremendous amount of work which I
shouldn't really say that I'm happy with
that my boss is in the room but it's ok
I don't I do like working at this
I don't like wiring up networking with
that I'm gonna switch to the present and
we're gonna move on to the next topic
which is storage where do I put my stuff
so at the file storage level we have two
products one with and we announced
recently and cloud storage I'm going to
talk through both of those options kind
of talk why you choose one over the
other so cloud storage is bucket based
storage we didn't you know that's
everybody does bucket based storage
right it's kind of a common metaphor we
didn't steal it for anybody with one set
of interfaces even though I have all
these different types I'm going to talk
about every time you deal with them
whether you're going through the console
or you're gone through CLI tools or SDKs
it's the same commands just with
different types of storage what are
those different types well we'll start
with multi-regional which is globally
available storage this is your stuff
that you want to push out as close to
your users as possible right you want it
to be for web content or videos or
mobile stuff right you want it to be
that when your users go to get it it is
as close to them as possible as opposed
to regional where what you really are
trying to do is you're trying to keep it
as close to the processing as possible
right like this is Big Data jobs or
maybe you need to stay in certain
regions of the world data it couldn't
can't leave it or other reasons right
but here the data is only in one region
and it's close to the machines you're
using to process it
now this doesn't mean that you can't
open up regional data to the rest of the
world like you can't like someone in
California can request something in the
European data center no you totally can
it's just the latency is gonna be a
little bit longer because it's not
duplicated as close to the user as
possible now we have two other options
in the year line and cold line both are
longer-term storage options near line or
for backups and long tail media right
there's stuff that you
you occasionally get to and it's planned
that you'd have regular access to it but
it's not something that you're getting
every day and then cold lying I like
they kind of say when you're downloading
stuff in cold line from cold line in one
browser window you have your resume open
in another right because it's for
compliance and disaster recovery stuff
stuff that you hope you never have to
pull so you want to store that right
because you have to store it but you
want to store it as cheaply as possible
and never ever use it so that's what
cold line is for this is kind of the
general costs for the in in the US and
they're different in different regions
but the deltas are always pretty much
the same multi-regional is two point six
cents forgave a gigabyte per month
regional is two cents per gigabyte per
month Nearline is one cent per gigabyte
per month and then cold line is the
cheapest at point seven cents per
gigabyte per month
there's also another cost involved which
is retrieval so if I go and retrieve a
file from multi regional regional we
don't charge you for like just accessing
the file whereas with a new your lining
cold line because we would encourage you
to kind of Park them and leave them we
have a one cent per gigabyte charge for
pulling down from your line and a five
cent per gigabyte charge for pulling
down from cold line and again that's
probably the least of your problems then
but just just now alright we have
another option which is called cloud
file store which we again
released recently it's basically managed
NFS and it's a shared file system you
get really low latency because you
connect it to the machines you're
actually using usually in the same data
center there are two service tiers a
premium and a standard it's basically
it's NFS the ten FS that we manage so
should we
what should we use well NFS is
attractive especially if I'm using it
somewhere inside but the fact of the
matter is is I want to share this data
with the world I don't want to do a lot
of work to do that if I do NFS then I
have to put some sort of system to share
on top of it I have to manage that with
with cloud storage as you'll see in a
second it just shares immediately and
it's pretty easy so I'm gonna use cloud
storage so let me give you a quick demo
of cloud storage I'm gonna switch to the
laptop again and here we go on the
laptop great I'm gonna go ahead and
create a bucket
I'm gonna call it tagger 102 I'm just
gonna create a default one and you'll
see that's it that's all I had to do
it's already created I'm actually gonna
upload files already so let's just
upload all the files from our app you'll
see that they push up they're going fast
fantastic now they're in cloud storage
and one of the things I love about this
is right right so let's see cloud
storage gladiator I'm gonna share it
publicly and when I do that I click
public link boom public that's how fast
it's like already there you see I've got
a URL for it now one of the other files
is a walk on app it cuz it's short I'm
gonna do a little you where I'll walk in
here ooh I did not mean that pun and it
came out though no it's terrible and
you'll see that I can URL walk and I
don't get it because those types of
permission sharing happen that fast so
cloud storage is sort of drop-dead easy
like it just boom works so with that I'm
going to switch back to presentation all
right
so gets up to cloud storage I could do
it via command line using GS util which
is equivalent to G cloud but for file
storage operations I can share publicly
by using G so till I am to do those
operations now one thing I'll point out
is that I shared one file within a
private bucket I don't recommend doing
that cuz that's when bad things happen
right that's when human error will take
over and I'll accidentally share
something you don't want to so what I
like to do is I have public bug buckets
and private buckets and I don't mix the
two but your mileage may vary do do what
you will but that's my advice
so my app needs to talk to these things
and to talk to the app I need to use
your client libraries and our client
libraries you see here are the languages
that are listed we also have REST API s
that are reasonably well documented if
you need to do it from another language
but I'm gonna use PHP because that's
what I used to write this app and when
to get done fast well when you use PHP
to move files that have been uploaded
used move uploaded file because it's
right on the nose that's the system
command to do it
and in C I take a source and destination
now to do this in using the SDK I can
need to do a little bit more code right
I need to use the right library I need
to create a storage client create a
storage bucket reference and then upload
the file but not a tremendous amount of
more work in order to accomplish the
same thing so basically I just swapped
that in and then our app is looking like
this now I've moved all the images to a
cloud-based solution the application
code is still living on the same machine
as the database and we should fix that
so let's go the next and talk about
application storage clearly we get here
we get the whole sequel vs. no sequel
conundrum I oh my phone is going off
because I am in dumb so sequel vs. no
sequel again this could under them and I
don't clearly have a winner although I
do hate one of them but I won't tell you
which the both of our valid both of them
do things so let's talk about sequel
first so cloud sequel is our tool for a
sequel it is a traditional sequel server
is vertically scalable we provide manage
backups and easy to set up replicas and
we make it easy to do high availability
vertically scalable means you can only
get it so big and then if you need more
resources you need a more powerful
machine you have to come up with some
other solution we also have something
called cloud spanner right which is for
structured data its sequel it's both
highly available and strongly consistent
now those of you that know cap theorem
may say that's kind of impossible and
cap theorem databases like what are you
doing here so what we did is we found
the guy who wrote the cap theorem we
hired a minima VP and he's kind of like
you could say it she's sort of close to
the truth
basically there are reasons why we can
say that there's a big white paper you
can read it it is both of these things
and it is amazing it's globally
distributed and horizontally scalable
which means you could keep adding stuff
if you need resources another place you
can add them another place it's
important to note that this is cost
effective it's scale for this app it
would be like massive overkill and my
boss would fire me because my bills
would be much higher than the real value
of tab
the app right so make sure that it's
cost-effective for you to use it but if
you have that type of scale it is
amazing talk about our no sequel option
the two main ones that I like that I use
a lot and I would use in this sort of
application is cloud datastore or cloud
fire store both are document based both
are indexable and it's hard to tell
sometimes the difference between the two
like when would you use one versus
another so I'll make it real easy if
you're doing stuff server-side you
probably want to use cloud datastore
right you're you're you're talking from
Google cloud somewhere else on Google
cloud you want that to be cloud
datastore if on the other hand you're
doing a lot with client work you're
doing a lot where you want to bypass the
server completely and just have data
stored directly from the client on to a
datastore cloud fire stores right for
you cloud fires sort of sort of a
marriage of some of our cloud datastore
technology and the expertise of the fire
of firebase team and so because of that
has a great web and mobile sdk and
really works well with those
environments okay
so which one should we use well I'm not
switching to no sequel because it was
built it was written in sequel and I'm
just I'm not switching the no sequel
that that would be like much more than
I'd want to do for an experiment like
this I cloud spanner is really overkill
and so what I'm gonna do is use cloud
sequel so let me drive cloud sequel a
little bit for you here's our sequel
machine I'm gonna go ahead and create an
instance you'll see it gives me a choice
between my sequel and post Postgres I'm
gonna choose MySQL you'll see here it
gives me some kind of pre-configured
options to make stuff easier I'm gonna
go with a development server and then
like mess it up let me do that I'm going
to call this Tager let's see
and then here's where I can have some
fun I can configure the type of machine
and storage so I'm gonna start right now
the the initial one is micro and you'll
notice over here that I have the
performance kind of meter how performant
this machine is going to be I'm gonna go
ahead and change the processor when I
change the processor you'll see that I
maxed out network throughput so if you
want more network throughput add more
processors to your sequel boxes on cloud
see
if I want better I ops well I can just
on you'll see here that as I increase
the number of I ops the disk throughput
and I ops and all that goes up and as I
add more eventually I max it out so if
you need higher performance out of your
sequel servers on cloud sequel that's
the way to do it and then I can also
enable automatic storage increases which
is great like if I'm getting close to my
disk instead of having to have a big you
know instead of not that not that being
here is a problem but if if I'm worried
about that I can just enable so that
it'll grow as my dataset grows so okay I
am going to cancel out of that and then
I'm gonna switch back to presenting to
do all right all right so how do I get
my data into cloud sequel while I do a
database dump right like I do my SQL
dump and then I do GS util and copy it
to cloud storage of all places
once it's in cloud storage I run sequel
import sequel to import that that file
and then after I import the file because
you shouldn't leave your sequel dumps
lying around in a public place that
could be made public you delete the file
now Oh safety tour this pattern of
pushing stuff to cloud storage and then
pulling it down elsewhere in Google
cloud platform it's kind of common and I
kind of see cloud storage is sort of hub
between a lot of different technologies
see this you have an application running
cloud functions you put a picture in
cloud storage and then manipulate it
with vision API or something else this
pattern of being a hub also applies to
cloud pub/sub which i'm not really going
to show off because it doesn't make
sense for this app but cloud pub/sub
does what for messages what cloud
storage does for files it basically acts
as a conduit in between all so it is a
messaging bus that does the publisher
subscriber model you have many
publishers or one publisher many
subscribers or one and then it'll make
sure that all the all those subscribers
get all the messages from all the
publishers okay I'll come back to that
all right now some common problems with
doing cloud sequel first one is you do G
cloud sequel and
you import a file and you get an error
right this is internal error okay I
didn't think it'd be an external error
but fine
alright internal error and then you dig
into it and you set up a verbose mode
and it'll tell you guys guys this was a
MySQL error which is really not that
much more helpful and I have a verb
filed I'm not bitter that they haven't
fixed it but how do you find how do you
figure out this problem so in the cloud
console there's this thing called
operations tab glut operations at the
top you'll see that have an error and it
even includes a line number so I can
like track this down and maybe see what
it is turns out that MySQL dump if you
had super privileges locally and you
might have because you're experimenting
with stuff and you accidentally up them
like I totally did in this case you
can't do that because we don't allow
super privileges on the box so so watch
out for that alright so what if you need
something we don't offer right like I
talked about cloud sequel I talked about
our our products but like maybe you need
Redis or maybe you need [ __ ] or
Cassandra or something well there's two
options you could always build it by on
hand usually build it by hand using
compute engine right because it's just a
VM you can install stuff on it we also
have a thing called cloud marketplace
which just recently was renamed if
you're familiar other platforms cloud
launcher it's now a cloud marketplace
and there are pre-built solutions for
things like the Sandra Redis [ __ ]
couchdb and more now it's important to
note that we will not manage these for
you right like we build them we need
like one click build these things but
then managing them is on you not it
won't be the way our sequel boxes are
all right so here we are all right we
got our App from a web application on a
single server and now we're running all
our state elsewhere and we have all our
code on a single server this opens up a
whole lot of possibilities for us right
because this is sort of the modern you
know the 12 factor app at least part of
it like we have application code running
one place and we don't have to we don't
have to store State anywhere and so we
can start mucking around with what we're
doing on this single server so let's
talk about some of our computing options
what do we use to build this stuff
so how do we scale this system now there
are a couple different ways of scaling
the system like what happens if tagger
like it becomes a breakout success and
won't happen I know it's fine won't
happen but what if it does well there
are a couple ways of dealing with this
the first way would be to use a
completely compute engine solution which
is a combination of using a managed
instance group and a network load
balancer so a managed instance group
which I'll talk about a little bit more
in a second is basically a collection of
VMs that perform the same role and could
be pointed at one load balancer and then
our load balancers our look balancers
which are pretty straightforward
that you don't kind of know what they
are so talk a little bit about them our
instance groups we could say that
they're managed or unmanaged I chose
managed for that because one of the cool
things about a managed instance group is
you can say things like alright because
all the machines are exactly the same
you create a template and they'll create
the same machine over and over again you
can say like I want processor
utilization to be at 60 if it goes above
60 spin up another box and because you
have a template it can spit up another
box and it's perfect and it perfectly
kind of fits what you're doing you can
also do unmanaged where like you can
build your own machines and add them to
it but then they could be different
profiles of processor and memory and
that sort of thing so we can't really
auto scale or auto heal them so that's
how you make a collection of VMs it all
do the same task you throw a load
balancer on top of them right and you we
have the the interface will show you
three different options will show you
HTTP TCP and UDP and you can make any
one of them local sorry internal only so
it doesn't it doesn't get exposed to the
public Internet so HTTP is our
equivalent of a l7 load balancer TCP UDP
is it equivalent of a l4 and then all of
them can be made internal only so we're
at a cloud conference and I have not
said docker
I have not said container and I'm not
said server list of what's going on
right I also haven't said a I so or Big
Data right but I'm gonna focus on
container and server lists these are
these are two terms that you typically
want to maybe consider moving your
container your
you're computing load - so what are
containers for those who might not be
familiar containers basically consists
of two things and this is if they're a
container expert through the room I'm
sorry I really oversimplified it but I
wanted to make it really simple for
people are not familiar with it so um
containers are made up of two parts one
a package file containing all of the
code and runtime components it takes to
process your your app or your micro
service or whatever you're running and
then you have an environment that tricks
that package into thinking it's the only
machine that's running it's only it's
the only system running on that machine
now this isn't and this is in contrast
to a VMware like you carve off bits of
the machine and say use 16 Meg's of RAM
memory and if it only uses 8 well then
that extra memory is gone you can't kind
of pull it back because it's been carved
off so doing it this way
these these containers are all kind of
tricked into using the same kernel I
don't I don't maybe that trick too maybe
they're just induced and courage or
something but what that allows them to
do is spin up very very fast because we
don't have a whole operating system to
tear up and tear down and we can fit a
lot more of them because unlike a vmware
you allocate blocks of resource these
will just these are just processes and
they use exactly as much memory and
resources that as they need and then the
rest is still free for other containers
to pick up and use so there are two
container solutions that I'd like to
talk about it at Google a platform you
obviously can spin up docker on a VM and
like there's nothing wrong with that and
we actually make it relatively easy to
do but the two container solutions I
like to talk about our good Cooper
neighs engine which is managed
kubernetes anybody here familiar with
kubernetes okay yeah that's intimidating
so good you all know it kubernetes is
for those of you that don't know CooCoo
Bernays is a container orchestration
system when you have one container it's
pretty easy to kind of keep track of
when you start having 20 30 containers
that are all part of different systems
that all need to be wired up to
different networking solutions it
becomes challenging to keep track of
them all and so Cooper Nettie's manages
that for Q um that's really
oversimplification now Cooper Nettie's
itself is a very large bit of software
to manage
Cooper nays engine is probably the
easiest way to run it because we'll take
care of like building all the machines
for you and setting up smart defaults
for monitoring logging DNS service
discovery and auto scaling we also have
this thing called App Engine flexible
which is much more simple you basically
create a custom runtime docker image
it's got to serve up on port 8080 and
once you do that we will scale it to as
little or as much as you need starting
at one so we'll leave it running all the
time you have one container one service
that's running one endpoint and if you
get a lot of traffic we'll just scale it
out and if you get less traffic we'll
scale it down much more simple but it's
it's it's better when you have just a
very simple thing it's a quick and easy
fix for a lot of this stuff all right so
what is serverless all right
service is the marketing term right we
all know it we're all in technology we
all know it's a marketing term because
we know there's not some sort of weird
octopus creature that these things are
running on it's the server right there's
a server somewhere and we know that
service is a lie but it describes
something for you the user the the
person consuming the service the server
has disappeared right because you don't
interact with it you don't you don't
ever have to worry about like setting it
up or like did I provision enough or
does it happen on memory like we take
care of that for you so service
describes a service where you pay as you
go for only what you use and you don't
think where the systems running on it
and that is actually a really cool thing
even if it is a marketing term all right
so serverless
we have two products that I kind of call
the service products that Google have
platform one is cloud functions which is
function based you write a function send
mail or you have one function since
email right you then attach them to
events so someone writes a file to cloud
storage you can attach a cloud function
to that and send mail you can attach
that event to a pubsub message you can
attach an event to a URL call so you can
actually make URL calls based on cloud
functions now if you need more than just
one function right you need to chain a
whole bunch of environment stuff
together and create a full application
well App Engine standard is probably the
way to go there right we have a number
of runtime for App Engine standard which
we announced today that we are we are
releasing some new ones in the near few
which is really exciting but basically
you have to write in these languages in
order to use app engine standard and
there's some restrictions like if your
if your software is based on like a C
executable that you wrote ten years ago
you can't pull that into App Engine have
happened and scale it but if you keep
with those constraint capabilities and
you just write code in these runtime
languages we will incredibly credibly
rapidly scale your application I have a
demo I'm not going to show it where I
take an app engine app that is cold that
hasn't been KITT in a day and I scale it
from 0 to 8500 queries per second in
less than 5 minutes
so 8500 QPS is pretty high but what does
it really mean 8500 QPS is about 30
million requests an hour or what
wikipedia does on an average hour so on
App Engine you can scale from nothing to
a Wikipedia level traffic site in less
than five minutes which is really really
cool and fun so the question is is like
so this this tagger service is saying
should I switch this over to one of
those and my answer is well it depends
right typical weasel IT answer it
depends because if probably not right
like it's just a simple app that I'm
running it's probably like a legacy app
that I've rolled over and I need to keep
going I don't know that I would move it
off a VM it's running fine just leave it
on VM but if like let's say I want
growth in this app let's say I wanted to
go bigger and better then maybe maybe I
would push it to containers right and
have it run with a whole bunch of other
similar services and get the most
resources out of my my my hardware that
I'm you know the virtual hardware that
I'm pulling down also if I have this
this app that's not very frequently used
running a VM all the time may also be
something that would be too much of a
cost so I might switch it over service
and take advantage of the fact that
server list you only pay for what it's
used it would depend on how much it's
used so my answers depends but for this
app I don't see it lighting up any time
in the future so I would probably leave
it on the VM
so conclusions one so we started here I
just kind of recap what we did we had a
single server app we moved it over to
this sort of configuration single server
which opened up a whole bunch of
possibilities to us of maybe switching
the containers or maybe switching the
server lists and we left our images and
our data elsewhere which was great we
did this with compute engine on the
single server side we did it with cloud
sequel on the database side and cloud
storage on the image side now I switched
those hexagons because one of the things
that we do is we kind of showcase all of
our products and I want to talk about
just how much we didn't talk about so we
talked about a lot of the compute stuff
which is great I'm happy we talked about
a number of this storage and database
options we talked about networking and
we talked about Big Data the cloud
pub/sub reference cloud vision API I cut
a demo so we didn't we didn't talk about
that at all we talked about cloud SDK we
talked about some of the management
tools but the entirety of cloud platform
is much bigger there's a lot more stuff
there I hope that as you look through
this sort of display of our stuff that
you see places where you want to go I
hope that I kind of showed you some of
it but we can we can see that there's a
lot more and if only there is some place
that you could go to which would provide
you with answers about the rest of the
platform like I don't know like some
sort of conference it would be great if
you could answer some of these questions
about what these things do
[Music]